the challenges facing our world are
growing all the time
how do we build stronger economies with
equal opportunities for all
how do we build a sustainable world for
generations to come how do we protect
our cities and harness the power of
technology for our common benefit
humanity has always been good at forward
thinkings we will make sense of the
problems of tomorrow
inequality
sustainability
urbanization
the gender gap
and the demographic time bomb
[Music]
the world is changing
today we stand on the brink of a fourth
industrial revolution one that will
transform the way we work the way we
live and even what makes us human
there's a group of technologies that are
combining to create transformation
across almost every industry at the
moment and those technologies include
things like artificial intelligence 3d
printing robotics
big data and then some things in on the
sort of life sciences front in terms of
genetics and and medical imaging and
that these things are sort of combining
in a way that's bringing about a host of
transformative changes across industries
i would describe the fourth industrial
revolution
actually quite similarly to how i would
describe the past three and that is
technology that leads to massive gains
and productivity and massive gains in
productivity mean
substantial improvements to everyone's
quality of life
the world has been through revolutions
before the advent of mechanization then
electronics then the digital revolution
all profoundly changed the world's
economies
but this revolution could be even more
disruptive
i think in previous revolutions you
could really talk about them as
industrial revolutions what was changing
was how things were made factories
industry often heavy industry in
particular here you're seeing
transformation across really a whole
range of not just industry but services
and and the creation of whole new
business models that didn't exist before
what's different a little bit about this
particular revolution is that
it gets into a whole range of things
that people only thought were ever only
possible for humans to do jobs that work
human jobs before aren't going to be
human jobs anymore
at the heart of this fourth revolution
is artificial intelligence the ability
of machines to match and perhaps one day
surpass the cognitive ability of their
human creators
what's happening now is a big deal
it is making a big difference in the way
people live uh the way people interact
with each other it is sort of
obliterating distance it is in some
cases removing humans from tasks that we
once thought were the sole province of
the human mind these analytic tasks that
we thought only a human brain could do
we're suddenly finding that algorithms
can do that machines can do
these are early days in the brave new
world of artificial intelligence but the
potential benefits are vast
what are some of the liberating benefits
of artificial intelligence they're
actually a lot if you think about
something just like driverless cars
autonomous vehicles which is one use of
ai that people are talking about that
could have a really liberating impact on
a lot of people's lives if you think
about older people who can no longer
drive they're very shut in their houses
right now very dependent on others for
transportation with driverless cars they
would be able to go about their daily
life
and then you're seeing with big data
that this may have a profound impact on
drug development that you'll find
new pharmaceuticals being developed at a
faster rate
to cure diseases because the computers
are essentially able to sort through the
data
and pick up connections that otherwise
would be missed
for health in particular the advantages
of machine learning data science are
immense those have an incredible chance
to address very both very infrequent
diseases and diseases which affect
different parts of the population very
differently if we're going to cure
cancer it's probably going to come
through data science
but there is potentially a darker side
to this technological revolution one
which could profoundly change the world
of work as we know it
[Music]
a technological revolution will cost
jobs it'll cost jobs in the areas that
see the biggest advancements first a
good example of that that is feasible
over the near term
is truck driving you have self-driving
trucks you don't need the 3.5 million
truck drivers that you have right now in
the u.s what is key as part of this
revolution as productivity goes up as
the economy continues to evolve and new
jobs are created you need to make sure
those displaced workers are given the
skills to move into these new positions
but that's what's key will all of them
be no but i think the key point is you
need to make sure if you've lost 3.5
million jobs in one sector how do you
create more than that in another sector
and i think in past industrial
revolutions that's what we've seen
happen and hopefully uh and i think it
will it will be what happens again
but what if this doesn't happen
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
he has peered into our future economy
and sees a world where potentially
hundreds of millions of skilled workers
are out of a job
i would say that if you look far enough
into the future there is no job anywhere
in our economy there's nothing that
anyone does that is completely safe and
that includes even artists and
novelists and you know the kinds of jobs
that you would imagine right now are
completely
beyond the scope of artificial
intelligence millions and millions of
those jobs are going to be lost
and it's unlikely that enough jobs are
going to be created to absorb all of
those workers
[Music]
martin ford is a software entrepreneur
who has a chilling vision of the future
his best-selling books have put him at
the forefront of a movement which
worries about technology the speed of
its growth and the immense potential it
has to change the world
this is the fourth industrial revolution
the advent of machines powered by
artificial intelligence which have the
potential to make redundant hundreds of
millions of workers across the planet
it is a world which is nearly upon us
but which governments and businesses are
only starting to comprehend
well the central idea in my latest book
the rise of the robots is that over time
machines computers smart algorithms are
increasingly going to substitute for
human labor i think that that's
inevitable
technology is eventually going to be
able to do many of the things that
people now do and i think there's a good
chance that that will result in
unemployment it's going to push people
out of the labor force many people are
going to find it impossible to adapt to
that because they're not going to have
capabilities that really exceed what
machines can do and that's i think going
to be a genuine concern both for our
society of course and ultimately for the
economy too
some of those machines are already with
us
there are already algorithms that can
interpret things like body language and
respond to some extent to emotion that
can determine your mood for example and
so forth and
you know this has big implications
imagine what that could mean for example
for advertising if an algorithm can
determine exactly how you're feeling and
then target
advertisements at you based on that
some of the language trans translation
things that have been demonstrated are
truly remarkable imagine if anyone in
any country who speaks any language
would now be able to do any job because
we have perfect
machine translation in real time between
languages so you know that has real
implications for the job market
obviously
we may already be starting to see the
effect on the wider economy in the first
decade of this century the net total
number of jobs created in the united
states
was zero
what we see is that in the united states
we've been having
what we call jobless recovery so
clearly there's something happening
there and i think part of what's
happening is that
jobs disappear when a recession happens
and then when
finally recovery comes back companies
find that they're able to leverage
technology to avoid higher rehiring a
lot of those workers and so it's taking
longer and longer for the jobs to
reappear
throughout history technology has always
disrupted economies and societies
in the late 19th century 50 of us
workers were employed on farms by 2000
it was less than two percent
those workers found work in other
sectors
but martin thinks this time it's
different
what transformed agriculture was a
specific mechanical technology
now we've got a technology that's really
just ubiquitous it's across the board
artificial intelligence is something
that's just scaling across our entire
economy it's not something that's
impacting just one sector it's something
that literally is everywhere and as a
result it means that there isn't really
going to be any safe haven for workers
what makes the new technology so
ubiquitous is the development of a new
virtual world the world of big data
well big data essentially is the
collection and use of just massive
amounts of data in big corporations for
example these companies are collecting
all kinds of information about their
customers about their business
operations about the actual processes in
in industrial environments and factories
about the things that their employees
are doing all of this data essentially
becomes a kind of feedstock for these
smart algorithms it it becomes the
information that they use to learn
and and basically to figure out how to
do things and that's something that is
just going to be i think dramatically
disruptive going forward
the total data stored on the world's
computers is now believed to be well
over 1 000 billion gigabytes
and it is big data which is driving the
most disruptive advance in technology
the ability of machines to think
[Music]
one thing that you'll very often hear
people say even today is that computers
only do what their programs do you know
this is really not right anymore and the
reason it's not right is basically
because of machine learning because we
now have this technology that allows
smart software algorithms to look at
data and based on that to to learn to
learn how to do things to figure things
out to make predictions so it really is
no longer the case that some human being
is sitting down and telling a computer
exactly what to do step by step
computers are now having the ability to
figure that out for themselves
you can imagine a future where every
device every appliance all kinds of
industrial equipment everything
communicates and talks to each other and
i think that one of the things will
happen is that
artificial intelligence will kind of use
that as a platform it will scale across
all of that everything will become more
intelligent
the last great technological advance saw
robots replace millions of blue-collar
jobs in factories and on production
lines
martin believes this new disruption is
going to target the white collar
workforce as well
once a
a computer learns to do something then
that that information can be scalable
out to any number of machines so it's
almost as like you can imagine having a
workforce of people and you could train
one employee to do a particular task
and then you could clone that worker and
and have a whole army of those workers
that's a bit like the way artificial
intelligence works so machine learning
is is very scalable if you've got the
kind of job where someone else another
smart person should maybe watch what
you're doing or study everything you've
done in the past and figure out how to
do your job then it's a pretty
good bet that eventually there'll be an
algorithm that will come along and be
able to do you know essentially that
that same approach so
that's a lot of jobs
many of the jobs which might be
displaced are those currently occupied
by educated highly paid workers
so you can see really across the board
that um anyone sitting in front of a
computer doing some sort of routine
predictable knowledge work for example
if they're cranking out the same report
or the same analysis again and again
all of that is going to be very
susceptible to this journalism is one
interesting area that's being impacted
by this because there are now systems
that can essentially tap into data and
then they can transform that data into a
very compelling news story that many
people would read and they can't tell
that it was written by a machine in the
future maybe 90 percent of new stories
will be machine generated
the number of jobs displaced has the
potential to utterly transform the
economic landscape
there have been a couple of studies done
most notably by a couple of researchers
at oxford university and they looked at
a number of countries and most of the
results have come back
suggesting that up to half of the jobs
could be susceptible to automation
perhaps over the next 20 years
that's 60 million jobs in the united
states alone
that's a staggering number obviously we
have a massive social problem you'd have
tremendous stress on government in terms
of trying to take care of all these
people that no longer have an income
i think that you would see
the potential for a massive economic
downturn because you would run out of
consumers you no longer have people that
are capable of buying the products and
services that are being
produced by the economy
a revolution on this scale wouldn't just
transform an economy it would have
immense implications for our society
we could really have just what you might
call inequality on steroids the very
wealthy people who own all this
technology are going to do
extraordinarily well
you would have the potential for civil
unrest perhaps even riots or
massive crime waves
in the united states during the great
depression we had an unemployment rate
of about 25
and
back then there were many people
genuinely concerned that that would
result in the collapse of both democracy
and capitalism
this situation amounts to just about the
end of the world as we know it a science
fiction nightmare straight from the
movies
there are some very prominent thinkers
like for example stephen hawking and
elon musk who have
raised genuine fears about the potential
for advanced artificial intelligence and
their concern is that someday we're
going to build a super intelligent
machine imagine a machine that's a
hundred or maybe a thousand times
smarter than any living person uh what
would that system think how would it act
would it have a use for us
it might decide that we're simply a
burden it might decide to just get rid
of us so it could potentially present an
existential threat
is that something to worry about i think
that it's not a silly concern it's not
something that we should laugh at and
just dismiss
[Music]
there's really
no end point to this there's no point at
which you can say this is absolutely as
far as we can go and there and machines
will never go beyond this we are
reaching a new era a time when things
are going to operate differently and we
need to adapt to that
healthcare is one area of the economy
already adapting to this disruption and
in this field researchers hope that
intelligent humans and intelligent
machines can work together for
everyone's benefit
[Music]
the fourth industrial revolution the era
of artificial intelligence has arrived
computers are now mastering tasks once
considered the sole preserve of humans
and putting millions of jobs at risk
and now business leaders are wrestling
with the potentially huge implications
in general robots of one form or another
are going to become much more
omnipresent in our lives in a good way
they'll replace a lot of repetitive
activities that people are currently
doing robots will have a dramatic effect
on the labor pool lower the cost of
products people will start to realize
that just about every manual task
eventually will probably be done by a
robot
martin ford's books have highlighted the
threat to the job market but even he
sees areas where artificial intelligence
could be beneficial
i do think that healthcare is actually
one of the areas where the impact of
artificial intelligence and robotics
could be extraordinarily positive in the
future the burden on our economy is
growing at a remarkable rate especially
in the united states so if we can deploy
more artificial intelligence and
robotics there to make that more
efficient that'll be a great thing
analysts expect the ai healthcare market
to generate revenues of over 6 billion
by 2021 10 times its current total
young companies like hindsight in new
jersey and analytic in california are
mining data to improve patient outcomes
across a range of illnesses
and in new york ibm researchers have
developed watson an intelligent software
system at the forefront of this
revolution it can understand somebody's
personality type
it can look at email for example and
tell you what is the tone of the email
uh you know what kind of messages are
coming through whether you internet them
or not right
it can look at for example a big
encyclopedia extract all the concepts
and the relationship among those
concepts
[Music]
watson operates in the world of big data
extracting knowledge from the billions
of facts and figures floating through
cyberspace
i look at the world from the point of
view of
you know the amount of data that there
is
and the amount of knowledge that is
embedded or insights that's embedded in
the data that we're not able to extract
today and therefore we are not able to
make the right decisions
so
um the fourth industrial revolution to
me is the ability to have a much
better understanding of the world
through all of the data and therefore
making better decisions for it
[Music]
ibm is currently running a research
project in which watson augments the
intelligence of medical professionals
helping doctors treat the most dangerous
diseases in the world
including skin cancer
[Music]
melanoma is a very deadly form of skin
cancer and it's something where early
detection and intervention is is key so
a dermatologist faced with a patient who
has a skin lesion will make some
assessment about the likelihood of a
lesion being melanoma
so unfortunately today dermatologists
can make errors some melanomas are being
missed
and some skin lesions which are
perfectly benign are being excised
needlessly
so what we can do here is essentially
ask the computer
to make a deep analysis over an image
so
this image is then being sent to the
computer and it's being automatically
analyzed
and what the computer is telling us
about this image is that there's a very
high probability that it corresponds to
melanoma
what we're finding in our own internal
retrospective research is that the
computer can be as accurate as 95
so this compares to the best clinical
experts today that are between 75 and 84
in recognizing melanoma it is not a tool
that would replace
uh the clinical expert
rather it provides them with additional
analysis over the skin lesion images
by providing reaches into large
databases of similar lesions
[Music]
this is a vision of a future where
humans and machines work hand in hand
complementing one another's skills
i look forward to a time when you know
every professional in fact you know two
three billion professionals around the
world are all able to have their own
personal cognitive assistant that can
help them do their daily jobs and that
changes the nature of expertise humanity
will move to a completely different
place in terms of expertise and how we
apply our knowledge and our experience
into real world problems and therefore
make the world a better place just like
we've had
machines that could
augment people's muscles in the in the
prior industrial revolutions uh or up
can help people
you know search vast amounts of
information like in the in the internet
era i look at the next revolution as
machines augmenting people's cognitive
capabilities um that's how i think about
it
martin ford remains cautious believing
artificial intelligence is going to
fundamentally change the way we live and
work
and challenge us like never before
we're not prepared for the disruption is
coming
we're gonna see
things get worse before they get better
in particular the impact on the job
market and the impact on the incomes and
the livelihoods for average people
so you know in the short term things
could be pretty difficult but in the
longer term if we do adapt to this then
i think there are reasons to be really
optimistic i mean you can imagine
an almost utopian kind of future where
no one has to do a job that's dangerous
or that they really hate or that's
really boring where technology takes on
more and more of that
and if we can get to that point of
course then that's a tremendously
positive outcome so i think that all of
that is really possible and it could be
one of the best things that's ever
happened to humanity but it will require
that we adapt to it and
that's going to be a staggering
challenge
[Music]
this is the age of the city for the
first time in human history more people
live in urban than rural settlements
the world's urban population is growing
by 70 million people each year 301
cities account for 50
of global gdp
this will rise to 66
by 2025.
so if we don't get things right in our
cities then the consequences for
humanity are profound
cities are critically important to
the global economy
and to progress in the global economy
cities can be sources of chaos
as well as development
[Music]
this dual personality of cities is what
makes them so alluring and so vital
[Music]
they can be dangerous places
but cities are where fortunes can be
made
one of the primary
factors driving urbanization is
opportunity you live on a farm and
you're growing crops you don't have a
lot of opportunity you see a bustling
growing city your friends are moving
there they're getting uh jobs and
offices maybe jobs in a in a
manufacturing center uh there's
restaurants there's culture there's life
this this is attractive uh this is
attractive and something you want to be
a part of
and everything is relative you know
they'll have greater access to schools
greater access to health care greater
access to employment and a much less
vulnerable
economic life
[Music]
in 1900 12 of the world's biggest cities
were in north america or europe
100 years later this number had fallen
to just two
most of the biggest cities of the future
will be in the developing economies of
asia and africa
most of the growth in cities is going to
be in china
india and nigeria
those three countries alone
will account for 37 of the world's urban
population just staggering numbers
here's an example lagos the biggest city
in nigeria
its population every year is adding the
equivalent of the population of boston
the urbanization rate in the u.s japan
it's over 70 percent in china it's still
50
so china may have a lot of mega cities
they may have a lot of larger cities but
those cities are either going to get
bigger or there's going to be more of
them so i think that's going to be a
trend and i think a lot of emerging
markets especially those with uh large
populations are going to experience
trends like that in the next 50 years
this incredible rate of growth makes the
challenges of managing a large city even
more
difficult the biggest risks facing
cities are the same risks that challenge
all of us
politically
governance
climate change
economic
inequality uh productivity economic
growth employment education
transportation those
issues that that face cities are the
same that face
everyone except on a much in a much more
concentrated way
one city battling with many of these
problems is rio de janeiro in brazil
alessandra orofino is on the front line
trying to solve them
she believes the world's biggest cities
are in danger of sinking under a tide of
poverty decrepit infrastructure and
citizens apathy and unless we do
something about it billions will suffer
the consequences
the kind of urbanization that we have
today can only go so far
if we do not change the way we design
our cities if we do not make cities
change with us we're going to have very
serious limits to urbanization
cities will become impossible to manage
impossible to live in and just very
miserable places to be i think if we
change that process those limits could
change dramatically and potentially be
non-existent but that requires that we
think deeply about the environments that
we want to be in and how we can better
build them together
[Music]
managing mega cities is one of the great
challenges facing the world
this is rio de janeiro brazil
nearly 12 million people crowd into its
metro area
it is beautiful and vibrant
but it also has its problems
crime
inequality
and poverty
alessandra orofino is an urban activist
and thinker who has lived and worked in
mega cities on three different
continents
she has worked with the united nations
on its sustainable development goals and
founded the groundbreaking mayu rio an
ngo that uses data gathered from
citizens to raise campaigns and solve
thorny issues posed by the rapid growth
of the city
mayor rio has 170 000 activists and
alessandra hopes it can become a model
for other rapidly growing cities around
the globe
we build upon a rich tradition of
neighborhood movements not only in
brazil but all over the world and try to
sort of bring it to the 21st century in
a way that makes sense for people
i was born in this city in rio de
janeiro and my family has a very sort of
mixed background my father comes from
a neighborhood in rio that was quite
dangerous in the 90s
quite poor
or lower middle class and my mom comes
from a very wealthy background one of
the best neighborhoods in rio it taught
me that this city can be amazing but it
can also be very rough and unequal and
that's not just
a characteristic of this city i think
it's something that we are seeing
increasingly in cities around the world
rio de janeiro is similar to many
emerging mega cities some neighborhoods
are as wealthy as anywhere on the planet
others remain impoverished and cut off
bridging this gap will alessandra
believes have profound benefits for us
all
cities bring people closer together and
they have this intensity in them this
density in them they are definitely the
places where most innovation will
naturally happen because it's very hard
to innovate when you're always talking
to the same people and hearing the same
thoughts and cities are the exact
contrary of that they are
natural hubs for innovation natural hubs
for economic growth and they tend to be
the engines of growth in most countries
but when this growth is rapid and
unplanned the results are gridlocked
streets poisoned air and an
infrastructure that simply cannot cope
well i come from a city that expanded to
rapidly for sure
how do you create sidewalks sewage
systems schools mobility systems
to cater to a growing population
if that rapid urban expansion is
happening in environments where
inequality is paramount
the challenges are even bigger
in a mega city one of the biggest
challenges can be simply getting from a
to b
our mobility systems in general very few
exceptions suck
when you have a poor mobility system you
just preclude entire segments of the
population from living the city from
actually accessing the opportunities and
the beauties and the amazingness that
cities have right because it's very hard
for them to get around you also preclude
the rich people in the city from getting
to know other areas in the city which
can be incredibly exciting and in a
fulfilling experience in and of itself
so you're creating a city in which
everyone is living in their own
territory which is terrible
at the forefront of these infrastructure
problems are the city's poor they can
become physically cut off from the
economic opportunities that living in a
city provides
the poor by the brunch of most things
and i think that includes rapid
expansion of cities the fact that in the
developing world one third of the
population is living in slums is
something that none of us should accept
as as we grow and as we think about the
planet in which we want to live
slums are a result of rapid unplanned
expansion
today an estimated 863 million people
live in slums
if the 104 million slum dwellers in
india were a separate nation they would
be the 13th most populous country in the
world but slums are not always hopeless
places
the poor are not just sitting waiting
for the government to do something for
them they're creating their own urban
environments so if you go to islam in
rio you see that most of that
infrastructure was built by the
community itself
over the years so there is a level of
do-it-yourself a level of initiative
that you see a lot more important
neighborhoods and rich neighborhoods
precisely because the government wasn't
there
this means slums must be handled
delicately by urban planners
what do we do with areas that were
developed by communities but lack
infrastructure even if we're assuming
good will in terms of how we handle them
even if the only thing that we want to
do is provide those areas with good
quality public services that are choices
that need to be made in terms of which
pieces of that infrastructure do we
leave which pieces do we change knowing
that it was built by the people if we
don't handle that process in a way that
is human and intelligent and actually
aimed at protecting the interests of the
poor communities we can end up with
massive waves of dislocation and and and
destroying an urban fabric and a social
fabric that is so important and so vital
in rio we have a neighborhood called
santa teresa and in that neighborhood we
have a tram it's a historical trend it's
beautiful
most trams in riya were destroyed
in the earlier in the 20th century
inside that that is that the neighbors
organized and capped their tram it's a
point of pride for them so that is it
was a forgotten neighborhood for a while
it became a lot poorer
and then in the past
five to six years it has been
gentrifying really quickly
and the government decided to turn that
tram which is one of the very few
remaining in the city into a terrorist
attraction but what the neighbors said
at that point was the only reason why
this tram still exists and it's vintage
and kind of hipstery and amazing it's
because we organized and we kept it here
they created that value they created the
richness of that community and we see
that all over the world
alessandra believes cities often ignore
this creativity the result is a
democratic deficit which erodes faith in
the city's government and alienates
already vulnerable communities
alessandra believes cities must take
their citizens with them if they are to
expand successfully
i think what we have definitely not
gotten right is the process by which we
involve citizens i have not seen one
case of a city that has really used the
collective intelligence of its citizens
and and distributed power in a way that
makes it actually possible for people to
influence the way the city evolves and
when we get that that right i think will
solve a lot of the other issues that we
see
but for us to truly harness the power of
our cities we need to heal the divisions
within them first
if we keep building unequal cities
cities that are not sustainable in
cities that are not very good to live in
for most of their population
i don't think we can actually hope to be
happy in these urban spaces the worst
case scenario for the global city of the
future would be
cities that do not have a soul and
therefore become
less and less attractive to
entrepreneurs to people who do want to
create new economic activity and that
ultimately also become less wealthy
across the ocean from rio another giant
city is growing
lagos is now the most economically
important city in africa
but its growing pains are excruciating
and threatening the futures of 21
million people
[Music]
more people live in cities than ever
before
[Music]
but many of the world's biggest cities
are struggling to cope
[Music]
lagos on nigeria's atlantic coast is the
largest city in the world without a
city-wide rail system
meaning everyone has to travel by road
for workers like abraham cole this means
his daily commute takes over his life
what time did you wake up
this morning i woke up like three
o'clock
three three thirty
[Music]
well i usually don't do breakfast
because it kind of slow me down
in three years the population of lagos
has nearly doubled from 11 million to 21
million
but this staggering expansion has
overwhelmed the city's impoverished
infrastructure how long should it take
you to get to the i should take me for
five minutes to get to the office
but in full traffic it full rush hour
how long was that you probably would do
like some
six
seven hours in traffic three hours going
three four hours coming back it's much
worse coming back
coming back is
is something else
and
i don't think i want to waste seven
hours of my
everyday time
for the rest of my life
[Music]
lagos is currently ranked in the top
five least livable cities in the world
but although the city's economy is
bigger than kenya's simply getting to
their desks is a daily ordeal for its
millions of workers
so when do you see your children
weekends
weekends only
sometimes
i see them during the week
if they really want to see me and
they're keen to see me sometimes they
miss me that much that must be quite
difficult
yes it is but
it's what we have to do
for now
[Music]
like millions of lagosian workers
abraham's first act on getting to work
in the morning
is to take a nap there we go
welcome to my office
so what what are you going to do now i
think i have
yeah this is quite early 7
10.
so i took a nap for like 30 minutes
and
get ready for work
[Music]
2 000 people migrate permanently to
lagos every day straining the city's
infrastructure further and expanding the
city from the land to the sea
[Music]
the result is slums like macoco a
floating settlement on the city's lagoon
the infrastructure has not kept pace
with the population growth so basic
measures of quality of life just as
access to clean water for example access
to electricity are are limited so before
you even get
to issues related to
uh
growth and and development uh lagos and
nigeria have to sort out much more basic
issues of infrastructure
makoko is the oldest slum in lagos
80 000 people live here in buildings
sitting on stilts connected by a complex
system of canals
successful cities find ways to deliver
services
to even the most uh
most deprived and that's that's the
challenge especially in the developing
world where resources are at a premium
in makoko residents have developed their
own infrastructure including fresh water
and electricity
and this three-story floating school
which doubles as a community centre is
the latest addition to this unique
environment
the school was completed in 2013 it is
cheap and easy to build
its designers hope it will become a
template for future buildings in the
cocoa
in nigeria raises interesting questions
of governance and control for example
it's been a
long ignored
area and the local residents took charge
and tried to improve their own lot with
schools and with their own locally
initiated development projects however
the central government also has decided
it wants that area for its own
development reasons
only a few kilometers away lies an
alternative vision of how lagos might
develop not a grassroots community
vision but a grand project of incredible
scale
echo atlantic
well where we are standing we are in the
alignment of the
financial district what we call
echo boulevard or some people call it
our fifth avenue this is where all the
major financial institutions will
establish their headquarters and offices
[Music]
echo atlantic is a multi-billion dollar
residential and business district built
on 10 square kilometers of reclaimed
land
it is in effect a new city
or it will be soon
its backers hope a quarter of a million
people will one day live here with a
hundred and fifty thousand workers
commuting from the old city across the
water
[Music]
when we
initially started to conceive equal
atlantic
obviously we looked at
canary wharf in london
we looked at dubai
and if you look at the heart of london
part of paris half of new york
obviously uh the vast majority of the
residents are
wealthy people i couldn't afford to live
in heart of london
but
it
in creating the residence for these
people you're also creating job
opportunities
and it is the the norm here in nigeria
that when you create
a residential apartment
you also create quarters for the
domestic staff working
for that family you have to take it into
context that this is
a city development this is not
a
low-income settlement it's a business
center primarily this is the future
for the commercial development of lagos
there's no doubt about it
[Music]
david hopes the first residential units
will be open by the end of 2016 with the
infrastructure of the whole site in
place by 2022
projects like eco-atlantic
raise as many questions as as they
answer
especially from where local residents
are aware that they may be getting the
short end of the stick on the other hand
they really do lend themselves to
uh
starting from scratch and being able to
build structures where there are
schools hospitals offices uh
transportation facilities and they they
give gigantic cities like lagos an
opportunity to create a model of what
can be presuming they're they're planned
and executed correctly
the future paths of mega cities like
lagos remain uncertain
organic citizen-led growth like macoco
or large-scale planned development like
echo atlantic
what's clear is that left unchecked
growth could destroy cities immense
potential
i'm an optimist when it comes to cities
i grew up in new york city in the 70s
when the city went to the edge of
bankruptcy
and here we are in the 21st century and
new york is is booming and thriving and
it's a tremendous place and you can see
with proper planning and a diverse and
vibrant population what's possible
i hope that those global cities will be
extremely interconnected in the sense
that they will have solidarity networks
in the sense that they will have
resiliency networks and in the sense
that their citizens will feel like their
cities where they want to be their
cities that is the sort of the project
that they want to build but they can
move they can visit each other they can
learn from each other at the global
stage
the world of work is still dominated by
men
in the middle east and north africa only
25 percent of women are economically
active globally three-quarters of unpaid
work is done by women
and even in north american companies 25
of female employees feel their gender
has held them back
if women are half the people
they should have you know a fair shot
for all of our benefit at contributing
to the economy in a way that is really
much more equal with men than maybe what
we've seen in the past of the biggest
companies in the world only about five
percent are run by women on corporate
boards less than 20
of the decision makers at the corporate
board table are women right now in the
u.s congress only about 20
of the elected officials in both the
senate and the house are women women
earn about 79 cents on the male dollar
so there's all kinds of ways in which
women don't have parity in the world in
which we live
this is the gender gap and it's been
around for a long time
the organizations that have a lot of
power in our world the elected
government
big companies the education structure
the medical systems all of these things
are really dominated by men at the top
and that's largely a result of the
history of the 20th century and before
that
and it is taking a while for women to
break that what we call the glass
ceiling but at the same time it's taking
a while for the whole society to adjust
to seeing men and women as equal actors
at the top of any of these institutions
nearly 100 years after women in the
united states were guaranteed the right
to vote the gender gap remains an issue
in every corner of the world
[Music]
and closing it has become more than just
an issue of fairness it has become an
economic imperative debated at davos and
in boardrooms across the world
the gender gap matters for business
it's the it's the market opportunity as
well as the potential loss to
to the bottom line you have a company in
a workforce that represents your market
you're more likely to succeed
by having a more diverse workforce
companies tend to be
more successful because they're able to
more creatively address
challenges and issues uh and uh you know
innovation and so if you have a
boardroom or a committee entirely
composed of individuals who all went to
similar schools and have similar
backgrounds and think the same way that
they're going to be less successful than
a very diverse board in a study that
came out last fall from mckinsey
they found in looking at a big
global
number of companies and looking at
economies around the world that in fact
equalizing women's economic contribution
by 2025 would add 26 trillion dollars to
the global economy so you know there's
really very big numbers related to
women becoming more equal in terms of
economic participation wherever you look
around the world
evidence is mounting of the positive
effect female voices can have at the
very top of businesses
if you look at companies where you find
female ceo or chair women
those are companies where you don't have
poor corporate governance they don't
have poison pills they don't have
unequal voting rights that keeps
you know insider management in control
they don't have
staggered board elections companies with
good governance are more likely to have
female ceos
so the question is with the issue at the
top of the economic and political agenda
what is holding women back from the very
top
is it lack of ambition
or simple old-fashioned sexism
so if we look at
professional women in the workforce
about 43 of them
leave their profession at some point to
deal with care of most likely a child
but also care of elderly relatives it's
very difficult to re-enter your
profession at the same level as your
male peers who have been present for
those last 10 years
[Music]
this explanation rings true for former
senior state department official anne
marie slaughter she believes that what
is holding women back is the structure
of our workplaces and societies and if
we don't do something about it then our
corporations and governments will
continue to underperform there's no
global issue
that would not be helped
by advancing women or achieving equality
we want a world in which every human
being
boys and girls has the right and the
ability to live up to his or her
god-given potential and what we have is
a world in which far more men have that
ability than women do
once upon a time women were promised
they could have it all
but something is holding women back from
gaining and retaining the very highest
positions in business and government
anne-marie slaughter has reached these
heights in her career
for two years she worked for secretary
of state hillary clinton helping to
shape the long-term goals of u.s foreign
policy and now runs the washington dc
think tank new america
but it was a 2012 article in the
atlantic which she subsequently turned
into a critically acclaimed book which
cemented her reputation as one of the
most intriguing and thoughtful
commentators on the question of women in
power
the feminist movement is about equality
it's about
women being able to have what men have
always had which is to be
fulfilled
in a job to to be powerful if that's
what you want to do important work or
work that is meaningful to you and have
a family too and i still believe that
women and men can do that i think
there's nothing that stops us in
principle from doing that but what i now
say is we have to make really big
changes still if we're going to get
there because as work is currently
structured as we think about careers
currently structured
far too many people do have to make a
choice and far too many of those people
are women
this was a choice which anne-marie
slaughter had to confront herself
work in the state department at a high
level is work that depends on the state
of the world and the world is
unpredictable by definition and there's
always too much work to do if there's a
revolution in egypt you can't say hold
that i'll be back on monday you have to
be there when it happens so i definitely
worked pretty much
very long hours for two years
when i went to the state department my
family understood that they were going
to sacrifice so that i could do
something i really wanted they stayed in
princeton i worked in washington i left
home at 5am on monday mornings and i
came back late on fridays and that was
difficult but i understood that that was
what it took to do this job my oldest
son was entering adolescence when i left
and he had a very stormy period
so much so that he started making really
quite bad choices a number of times i
would just jump on a train and go home
you know in the middle of the day and
then secretary clinton was incredibly
understanding
but after two years we realized that
it really was a choice between
putting all our energy into helping him
get back on track with real important
life consequences
or
you know getting promoted in a career
that i had i loved
the decision to quit her dream job and
leave washington didn't just affect
anne-marie's career it challenged the
feminist credo by which she had lived
her life
i saw the world differently i realized
that i had been telling women for
decades young students whom i taught you
can make it work you just have to you
know work hard and you can make it work
and i couldn't make it work and if i
couldn't make it work with all the
advantages in the world i had money i
had a husband who was a lead parent i
had every possible way to make it work
well then you know then there are places
where we simply have to make choices
that was an epiphany
anne-marie's decision to put caring for
her family before advancing her career
saw her accused of betraying feminism
when i wrote my atlantic article i got a
great deal of criticism from
women of my generation or older
who were feminist women i admire
but who very much worried that i was
setting the movement back
if i told people i'd come back because i
wanted to be with my family i got a
reaction that essentially told me among
many people and many women
that they saw me a little differently
than they had before that i wasn't
really a player that i'm i wasn't as
motivated or ambitious as they thought
i'd been kind of disappointed
anne-marie's experience sparked a debate
about whether women can have it all
facebook ceo sheryl sandberg had
suggested that in order to get ahead
women needed to be more assertive in the
workplace in the face of male power
they need to lean in more
[Music]
i admire sheryl sandberg and i admire
what lean in has done i've seen it as
somebody who runs an organization i have
seen young women come in and ask me for
raises and i know that they've just read
lean in you know that they're they're
doing it you know they're pushing
themselves forward in exactly the way
that sheryl sandberg recommends and many
women
advocate and i agree with all of that i
think it is a debate
about where to put the priority
anne-marie believes the problem lies
deeper not just in women's individual
behavior
but in the way business and society is
structured to make it almost impossible
for women to have a career and to care
for a family at the same time
that's a full-time job
and
somebody has to do it and women have
traditionally done it so women are still
expected to do it so what you're doing
is asking people who are holding two
full-time jobs to compete with people
who are holding only one so if a woman
is the primary caregiver for her
children or for her parents and a
full-time breadwinner she's competing
with people who are doing only one of
those that's like running a race
and having half the people you know put
a pack of rocks on their back and
wondering why they don't advance to the
finish line at the same pace
instead of saying well that's something
that women should still do while they're
also working we need to say
parents
should have the time and the space to be
able to care for their children and also
work but that requires a much bigger
shift in thinking
[Music]
[Applause]
the effect of the gender gap can be seen
across the global economy
[Music]
rates of prime age employment for women
have been falling in the united states
for nearly two decades
in 2014 just 70 percent of women aged 25
to 54 were in work
[Music]
the comparable figure is higher in
scandinavian countries and these are the
countries where the gender gap is at its
narrowest
the countries that have gone the
farthest toward real equality are the
nordic countries denmark and sweden and
finland and norway
what they understand is both that you
have to recognize that raising children
is a social and economic investment and
their governments say we're going to
invest in maternity leave and paternity
leave and the paternity leave is
particularly important because they
create incentives
for men to take not a week not two weeks
but up to six months
and they do that in part by giving one
month or sometimes two months as a kind
of use it or lose it so the man's an
idiot if he doesn't take
the month to be with his children when
if he doesn't do that he just he loses
that leave right that's crazy
if sharing the burden of care of
children and of parents is key to
closing the gender gap then that
suggests accepting the traditional roles
of men and women are a thing of the past
you have to be
accustomed to seeing men
as the primary caregivers of young
children and men have to understand that
they're just as good as women at this
and
even
more important or equally important in
many ways as a
finnish
ceo said to me the head of a big finish
company he said
now when someone comes a young man who
hasn't taken their paternity leave i
wonder about their character
and that's where we have to go
and in scandinavia that's where they're
heading
the nordic nations are pioneering a new
approach to work and parenthood and
narrowing the gender gap in the process
[Music]
across the world women are reaching the
top in business and politics but they're
struggling to stay there
[Music]
i call myself an impatient optimist i'm
impatient because the world is getting
better for women but it's not getting
better quickly enough and we need to do
a lot to move that forward and i i would
love to tell you that because i'm a
female ceo
i've changed the fabric of the diversity
makeup of my own company and i'm leading
by example but the reality is is that
we're challenged in terms of uh female
representation it's not getting better
in fact you know post the crisis there
was less diversity on wall street than
pre the crisis and one would have
thought it would have been the opposite
right so i would take the opposite side
not getting better and it's costing wall
street a lot of money
[Music]
anne-marie slaughter thinks this gender
gap exists because of the way businesses
and government treat family life
in sweden along with its nordic
neighbours attitudes are different
scandinavia leads the world in gender
equality but its success has been hard
won
i did military service when i was 20
years old
and we were three women in a group out
of 60 people
i came in as top 10 out of 60 on a half
marathon with 15 kilos on my back
and
they said that i was lucky
and they continued to say that i was
lucky when i was at a shooting range or
did my exams well so my performance
wasn't valued as much as the guys
sophia has made it her mission to
challenge this culture
sweden is
is viewed as one of the most generical
countries in the world and we are if we
look at you know legislation and the
fact that you actually can combine
family and career and we see also that
we are
are very
above eu average when it comes to women
in the workforce but if you look into
the managerial positions we are not
there
we we drop out and we are actually below
the eu average i think the eu's average
is 27 female managers and in sweden we
are 23.
sophia's job is to help smash the glass
ceiling in the swedish private sector
we are working with companies that were
constructed hundred years ago
so when they did recruitment where they
communicated when they gave feedback
when they interacted with their clients
they did that in one certain way
and
they still do it but the world has
changed so the glass ceiling is
basically old norm's own culture so you
have to change the culture to get rid of
the glass healing
80
of the global
consumers are women today and they are
powerful they have more money than
before 64 of the university graduates
are women so the future is female
if you don't know how to
meet predict
their needs you will not be here
while sofia tackles business culture
swedish family life is already moving
towards parity between men and women
sophia splits the care of her two
children equally with her husband harry
who also has his own demanding career
for me as a ceo or another company
[Music]
i work hard i get up early
but i'm also totally focused from five
to eight on the kids
we split 50 50 with the kids when when
they were small and before kindergarten
and
this gives me the best of two worlds
i work hard i have a fulfilling job
but i also get to
really know my kids
we have uh
40 years of career
spending six months with the kids is one
of the best investments you can do
this shared attitude to parenting is
typical in scandinavia tdc is one of
denmark's leading telecommunications
companies with revenues of over 3.5
billion dollars in 2015. the company
offers generous parental leave to its
nearly 9 000 employees believing it to
be good for business as well as families
i definitely think that the the labor
market in denmark compared to other
countries are much more uh free giving a
high degree of responsibility to our to
our employees and and ask them to to to
feel
feel free to to have a whole life and we
see our employees as a and as a human
being as a whole 360 degrees around
tdc offers fathers 100 of their salary
during 16 weeks of paternity leave
like sophia's work in sweden the aim is
to change the culture around work and
families the result is a take-up rate of
85
and the company believes a happier more
productive workforce
there's no doubt that
we have seen increased productivity
levels for our employees of course we
can attract
more competent people because we have a
more balanced focus for the job between
your private life and your your work
life
that's that's for sure
senior manager peter jesperson is a
veteran of paternity leave
he's able to split care of their three
children with his wife christine who
then feels the benefit in her own career
peter is allowed to spend four weeks
with me at home right after the baby is
born
and then when i go back to work
he has the per the first couple of
months he stays at home with the kids
which enables me to
start working without having any duties
at home but then i can focus on work
i'd say that that what other countries
or and other people probably could be
missing out on is is two things probably
i think
one thing is the family side i mean
both parents get to know their children
they get to know their preferences they
get to know who they are
and i think on on on the work
environment workplace
i think there's numerous studies that
shows that equality if you promote
equality being both having women in in
top positions women's and managers jobs
and women in the work place in general
you will you will
be more successful so so as a as a
society as a whole
moves towards gender equality in
scandinavia have not happened by
accident they're the result of a
deliberate long-running strategy
i think it's critical to how we live now
and how we go forward that the gender
gap and broader issues of diversity are
part of the conversation and that is
really because of the way the world is
changing the gender gap is part of it
and it's not going anywhere so it's
important for us to talk about it i want
my daughter to grow up in a world where
she can be anything so i think it's
about
you know
breaking norms and enable both men and
women to be who they are
gender equality is a huge piece
of
cultivating
and harnessing
human talent
and that's the way to think about it
that
we need all the talent we can find
because we have enormous problems
because we need economic growth because
we need innovation because we need to
save the planet
we need
human
ingenuity
creativity intelligence
and half of that
talent
is in women
[Music]
you